-Our next guest is
a voting-rights champion,
best-selling author,
former state representative,
and current candidate
for governor of Georgia.
Her children's book
"Stacey's Extraordinary Words"
is on sale now.
Please welcome back to the show
Stacey Abrams.
How are you, Stacey?
-I am quite well.
How are you?
-I'm doing fantastic.
I feel as though you had
a better week than I did.
For one, I'm at home with COVID,
but also, I am not
a Georgia Bulldogs fan.
And you were tweeting
about the game.
You were watching it
with your father.
Who was more excited,
you or him?
-My dad.
There is no way to beat
a high school football star
when it comes to excitement
about a college football game.
I don't even bother trying.
-Was it a fun father-daughter
evening to watch it together?
-It was delightful.
So, he got his start by becoming
famous on Instagram.
He did not really understand
what that meant
until my 15-year-old niece
pointed out that 100,000 people
had liked his post and that
someone called him adorable,
which just made the halftime
for him.
-[ Laughs ]
-And then we won.
So, and my father grew up
in Mississippi,
so he grew up with a deep
animosity towards Bama.
So, you know, it was
a full-circle game for him.
-That's fantastic.
Congratulations to both of you.
So, I want to start
by talking about the fact
that speeches this week
from President Biden
and Vice President Harris
in Atlanta
about the importance of passing
voting-rights legislation --
you were absent.
You said it was
due to scheduling.
But there were other
voting-rights groups
who boycotted the event
due to the slow progress
on voting rights.
How do you feel about people
sort of using your absence
as maybe a reflection on
the lack of Biden's popularity
in Georgia right now?
-I think we are missing
the point, which is that we have
a president who understands
the attack on our democracy
that we talked about last week
when we remembered January 6th.
But more importantly,
he's looking to a future
where we should all be able
to participate in our elections.
And even the groups
that were dispirited
have become re-engaged
and re-energized,
and that's because
the president is doing his job.
He is a champion for voting
rights, and I'm proud to be
united with him in that fight.
-You talked a great deal
about voter suppression.
Now you're running in a year
where I wouldn't say
most pundits are bullish about
the chances for Democrats.
How do you feel Georgia is tied
to the sort of national polling,
right now, that is maybe not
looking particularly good
for your party?
-Polling reflects
what people are feeling.
But running for office is about
telling people what's possible.
And I'm running on possibility.
I know it is possible for us
to get healthcare for Georgians.
I know it's possible for us
to fully fund education.
I know it's possible
for us to acknowledge
the pain people are feeling
economically,
but build a stronger
economic future.
And that's what
I'm going to focus on.
And I think that's what we all
have to talk about.
We cannot ignore the real pain
that people feel today.
But part of the responsibility
of leadership
is to set a vision
for what's to come.
And that's what
I'm going to run on.
-This looked, for a long time,
like it would be a rematch
between you
and Governor Brian Kemp.
And yet there is a Donald Trump
candidate, David Perdue,
who is primarying Kemp.
Is that something
you focus on at all?
Do you enjoy the fact that
there are two candidates
who are going to
eventually face off,
one of them is going to
face off with you,
sort of slinging mud
at one another right now?
-There is a proverb that
I have completely appropriated
and twisted a little bit,
and it says,
"When elephants fight,
stay off the grass."
I'm focusing on Georgia.
I will let them do
what they want.
My job is to fight for
the future of Georgians.
-A lot of focus has been
on Senator Joe Manchin
from West Virginia
and the power he sort of holds
over the Democratic Caucus
right now.
Do you feel like that has
sort of fogged over the fact
that Georgia won these two
runoff elections,
and Democrats could be
in a far worse place right now
than just having Joe Manchin
as a tipping point?
-I think we have to remember
that America would be
in a far worse place but for
Senators Ossoff and Warnock;
that because of them, we have
seen child poverty cut in half;
because of their two votes
added to the litany,
we have seen
the American Rescue Plan;
we've seen
the infrastructure bill;
we are seeing progress
being made on so many levels.
And a lot of Republican
governors are getting to spend
money that Democrats have
delivered into their states
to make certain that Americans,
regardless of who
they voted for,
get the services they desire
and the services they need.
And that's why I'm so proud that
I got to be part of making sure
that Jon Ossoff
and Raphael Warnock
are in the U.S. Senate.
-We have talked, every time
you've been on the show,
about the fact -- about
how impressed I am
that you still manage
to be an author.
Not just a reader, not just
a lover of television,
but an accomplished author,
across many different genres --
political thrillers,
suspense, romance.
And now you've written
a children's book.
How is that different than
the other experiences?
-Children are hard, man.
It is hard to write for kids.
[ Chuckles ]
You've got to write a book
that they will sit still for.
You've got to write a book that
their parents won't despise you
for having to read over and over
again if they like it.
And you have to take this
complicated story in your head
and not make it simple, but
distill it down so that it fits
into a much shorter space
than a 100,000-word thriller.
And all in -- and make sure
that the art is amazing,
which luckily
I had nothing to do with,
because Kitt Thomas is
a fantastic artist.
-I know you're very close
with nieces and nephews.
Did you use them as
a sounding board for this book?
And what was the sort of
feedback they gave you?
-I did. And they were --
They are harsh critics,
but I satisfied them all
and got to a place where
I could show myself
at our holiday dinner
and they were pleased
to show their new books
to their friends,
so I passed the test.
-And now, when you're on
the campaign trail,
when you're traveling
around your state,
do you still find time
to read?
And what sort of things
do you like to read
when you have sort of maybe
bigger, heavier topics
on your mind 24/7?
-I read everything.
And yes, I read every day.
Right now, I am finishing up
"Harlem Shuffle"
by Colson Whitehead.
I have a romance novel
by Nora Roberts
that just makes me happy.
And that's going to be
the reading I do this weekend.
And then I will find something
very heavy and weighty to read
because, well, why not ruin,
you know, my tomorrow?
-So, I think a lot of people,
maybe not just the voting-rights
groups that boycotted
the speeches by the president
and vice president this week,
are frustrated
by the lack of progress
and don't feel particularly
optimistic about
any sort of voting-rights bills
getting through Congress.
You are somebody
who's in this every day.
Is there a reason for anyone
to feel optimistic right now?
-Absolutely.
I live in Georgia, the heart
of the civil rights movement.
But, more importantly,
I'm the daughter of Robert
and Carolyn Abrams,
who fought for civil rights,
they fought for voting rights.
My parents lived through,
you know,
the first 20 years
of their lives, basically,
without full citizenship.
I think we can wait another
few weeks and few months
to get to where we need to be,
because, ultimately,
it's the goal.
And one thing I talk about in
"Stacey's Extraordinary Words"
is perseverance,
that we may not get what we want
in the moment we want it,
but our responsibility is
to never give up hope
and to never give up
the work we have to do.
The work is not done yet.
The work remains,
and we can do it.
And that's what we saw
from the president this week,
that's what we are going to
continue to see
in the U.S. Senate,
and that's what
I'm going to continue to do
because I believe
in perseverance.
And I can spell it, too.
-Now, your book is about --
you mentioned spelling.
Your book is about a girl
who enters a spelling bee.
This was something -- words
and their correct spellings
was something that you had
an early passion for, correct?
-I did, indeed.
-How would you go about --
Yeah, I'm sorry. Go ahead.
-Oh, no, I was going to confess
my poor spelling of a word,
but go ahead.
We can live that ignominy later.
-Well, did you actually try
to learn how to spell words
as a kid, and how would you
go about it?
-I actually --
I didn't keep a notebook
of extraordinary words,
but I did love words.
And my mom was a research
librarian when I was growing up,
so when she said,
"Go look it up,"
there really was no excuse.
And after a while,
I would look up a word
and then read the words above it
and below it.
Eventually,
I read the dictionary,
which, again, would not
recommend as bedtime reading,
but was fun for me.
And I kept a list
of words that I liked.
And so spelling words
became a fun thing.
-So, does that mean
that when you get a manuscript
to your editors,
be it for a children's book
or for a suspense thriller,
is it hard for them to find
a misspelled word, do you think?
-I do not misspell words, no.
-Okay, gotcha.
What is your worst misspelling?
-So, my very first major
misspelling was "chocolate."
-Okay.
-I am Southern.
I had never heard it
pronounced chock-o-late,
so I did not know
there was an extra "O."
It was devastating to me
to learn it onstage
that there was a second "O"
in "chocolate."
So, that one sticks with me.
-Wait, onstage?
Do you mean -- so you misspelled
this in a bee?
-Oh. Oh, yeah.
My very first spelling bee,
misspelled the word "chocolate."
Yeah, it was devastating
on multiple levels.
And as you can tell,
I've gotten over it.
-Yeah, no, it's great that
it's not following you around
like a cloud
all these years later.
-No.
-[ Laughs ]
Hey, thank you so much
for joining us.
Congrats on the book.
Congrats on Georgia football.
And we do hope
to see you again soon.
-Thanks, Seth, so much.
It's always a pleasure.
-Stacey Abrams, everybody.
"Stacey's Extraordinary Words"
is on sale now.
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."